you know it's always good to be bill
murray but especially in this moment
rach oh yeah bill's got a lot going on
kev but let's start with the marvelous
rumor of an on-screen reunion with his
ghostbusters afterlife co-star paul rudd
say you were going to take on
a villainous character opposite
the world's sexiest man alive mr paul
rudd in a third ant-man film cool what
would your villain look like we'd have
to give him a wig
and we'd have to hopefully just apply
facial prosthetics maybe extra teeth
okay bill's tight-lipped about his role
in the next ant-man movie due out next
year but he did reflect on a big
anniversary he has this year 45 years
since you joined snl well i know i've
been paying my phone bill for a long
time now so it's probably that that's
what i was celebrating
[Music]
of course bill's singing on snl has been
an inspiration to many including this
guy this is a drake song i miss my ex
this is a drake song pete davidson he's
having a moment right now what do you
make of him bill i enjoyed the um
that staten island thing uh walking in
memphis to walk into staten island that
was good i'll enjoy that
[Music]
at 71 years young bill's still singing
but this time he's doing it with a
classical ensemble including
world-renowned cellist john vogler the
final performance of their 55 city world
tour featuring poetry and music is now a
feature film new worlds the cradle of
civilization in theaters february 2nd i
heard bill sing in jungle book
wherever i wander
wherever i'm wrong i thought wow he can
sing so well i texted him said i think
we can do a show and go around the world
i feel charming
oh so charming this movie comes out
february 2nd of 2022.
that's nice i do believe that's also
groundhog day well it's groundhog day
it's on tv all day long and
if you're walking in the streets like in
a place like new york city you will see
someone will see you
you know because they it's been someone
on the street has seen it in the last
six or eight hours
[Music]